[Music]
Salzburg has plenty of beautiful things
to offer mountains at the rock town
center an impressive medieval fortress
and one of Austria's best-known shopping
streets get high de Gaza tour guide in
Israel has a few tips on where the
locals like to go
[Music]
Cafe classic for instance
this is it's mine father the hot
chocolate here is my favorite the cafe
classic is on the ground floor of the
house where Mozart lived not many people
know about it it's a place locals enjoy
and I'm one of them
the first floor of the building called
the Mozart residence houses museum
pieces you can only touch the keys of
these instruments if you have special
permission this is it's the size this is
the Mozart family's old pianoforte
both cam himself played on it
steingasser
is also largely unknown to tourists even
though it's in the oldest part of salt
pork the first houses were built here in
the 11th century these distinctive
grooves are much newer
[Music]
this is knocked incitement they were
made after World War two when the
Americans were here in Salzburg the GIS
the young soldiers tried to drive into
this narrow lane with a tank because
there was a brothel back there
unfortunately the GIS had had a few
beers they got stuck and had to be towed
out on sinthome fists kafan the people
here in science book found the stories
so funny that they left the marks this
is poor and [ __ ] last nerve
the people of Salzburg aren't just proud
of their history the Museum of Modern
Art at first a controversial
construction has attracted thousands of
visitors since 2004 - first of all the
location is fantastic
from up here you have a great view over
the city and then I think it's
incredibly important that in addition to
the Baroque the old and traditional we
have new things and the museum is the
perfect place for that blood stuff here
and here's a relaxing way to end your
day in Salzburg in m32
the restaurant in the museum building